as rescuers hold out hope at the
collapsed surf side condo building
saturday brought more grim news today
our search and rescue teams
found another body in the rubble
and as well our search has revealed
some human remains forensic experts will
use dna samples
already collected from family members to
quickly identify the remains
officials reported making progress
battling a fire at the disaster site
that has been hampering rescue efforts
our top priority
continues to be search and rescue
and saving any lives that we can the
spiegel family is searching for
any news about their mother 65 year old
judy spiegel
my mom is a fighter i know she loves us
i know
she doesn't want to give up as
investigators work to determine what
caused the collapse
an engineer's report from 2018 found
abundant cracking
in concrete columns beams and walls in
the building's parking garage
and major structural damage to a
concrete structural slab
caused by failed waterproofing but the
report did not indicate those issues
could lead to a collapse
surfside mayor charles burkett says he's
working on a plan to temporarily
relocate residents of a sister building
for those that are frightened and
concerned
i wanted to make sure that they had
options miami-dade county officials say
they're reviewing the safety of
buildings
40 years or older elise preston cbs news